I'm swimming we're running from Amazon
and I'm going to show you a demo for
analyze tool consider this employee
payroll spreadsheet suppose you want to
compute the total pay for all the
Capitol Hill barristers you can issue
this command in English and when you hit
the apply button then our system
translates the natural language
description into a program but you see
on the right side and then the program
is run on a spreadsheet to compute the
desired result a key aspiring goal
behind the system is to enable
robustness to variations in how
different users may say things on one
hand our system can assign an
interpretation to a bunch of keywords so
if you say sum total pay capitol hill
baristas our system can interpret it on
the other hand our system can also take
as input a much more Volvos description
such as computer please sum the total
pay values for the Capitol Hill location
baristas the technology behind this tool
is similar to the one used in flash fill
there is an underlying domain-specific
language to which we translate the
natural language into the language has a
rich type system and we use a
combination of type based program
synthesis and rule-based program
synthesis to enable both high precision
and high recall since the system is
based on foundational programming
languages technology it enables
interpretation of complicated commands
as compositions of base operators for
example you can ask who has a total pay
that is larger than the average total
pay and the system will find it for you
another key aspect in our system is that
it is easily extensible and can support
a wide variety of commands such as sum
the total pay by title and the computer
ends up generating a small little table
here you can even say 'lord the total
pay by title and the tool will end up
generating a nice chart for you